well I know there's big national news
happening right now but I did announce
some big personal news yesterday which I
will lead with briefly out of sheer
self-indulgent narcissism
we are expecting wall wall child number
four in in our house my wife is due in
October we don't know the the gender yet
and honestly how dare you even think of
asking me such a question because of
course our children are allowed to pick
their own genders and their own names
and their own ages which is why my
oldest is named fart poop and he's six
thousand years old and his gender is
pirate so you know we just that's how we
that's how we approach things anyway
we're excited about that but arguably
the bigger news nationally is the molar
report which was finally released a
redacted version a lot of a lot is being
made of the redactions but the vast
majority of the report can be read I
mean you know if you if you skim over it
most of its there the stuff that's
redacted is clearly is clearly omitted
because of ongoing investigations
although it is kind of fun and exciting
to read a report with all these
redactions and stuff because you feel
like you're reading some sort of secret
document or something but other than
that I don't think the redactions mean
much now it is a four hundred plus page
report two volumes it's basically like
reading crime and punishment or
something in terms of in terms of length
so I have not read the whole thing
obviously just came out a couple hours
ago nobody right now has read the whole
thing and in fact anybody who offers
their opinion on this report at any
point over the next day or two probably
has not read the entire thing but the
good news is that the report is very
handily organized so that you can look
at the major conclusions and and and and
other parts of it to get a general idea
of what's going on plus we have bars
press conference that he held this
morning summarizing it plus the
four-page letter that he put out
summarizing and I think all of that
gives us an idea a pretty good idea
of of what's going on in the report now
in a perfect world honestly I would just
say nothing to you about the report at
all right now I would just ignore it and
talk about other things and I would
maybe we would all just take a week to
let it to let the whole thing digest and
to really read it and take our time with
it but that's not the way things work
now and I don't really have that option
so I will offer a couple of very basic
general points about the report the
report is as I said in two parts two
volumes
the first volume deals with the
collusion aspect of thing and and and
also with Russia's interference in our
election the second part deals with
claims of obstruction that Trump tried
to obstruct the investigation as for the
first part it actually seems pretty
simple now let me read Muller himself
summarizing if I could pull this up
Muller says the investigation did not
establish that members of the Trump
campaign conspired or coordinated with
Russia or with the Russian government in
its election interference activities
okay so that's the ones half a sentence
right there but but it's in a way that's
that's all you really didn't need to
know as far as collusion goes right that
they said there was we did not establish
as no evidence that that collusion
happened
now obviously the truth the report
doesn't say Trump is absolutely
vindicated on this score he's an
innocent man you know let leave him
alone you know the the that statement is
not in the report that statement
wouldn't be in the report whether it was
true or not now on the other hand it
also makes clear that Russia did
interfere in the election there was a
coordinated coordinated campaign by
Russia to try and help Trump get elected
a campaign that they hatched for their
own reasons you know we can theorize
about why they would rather have Trump
than Hillary but they had their own
reasons for Trump had no hand in and in
devising it there's no evidence at all
that Trump was meeting with them or
sending people to meet with them
hatching a plan about hey guys how are
we gonna get me elected that's not what
happened now that is what the left
assumed happened and that's what they
claimed for two years but that's not
what actually happened
Moeller investigated this for two years
himself and did not find evidence of it
how much did Russia's involvement in the
election sway things well again that's
not gonna be covered by this report
that's not the point of the report I who
knows it's all hypothetical I tend to
think that Russia's involvement probably
didn't have that much of an effect at
all I think the you know the the emails
I really doubt that there were that many
people who were going to vote for
Hillary but then the emails came out and
they said never mind I'm gonna vote for
Trump I think this was the emails
functioned just as something for
conservatives to talk about and they did
they did help Trump in that way because
there were also scandals on Trump's end
you know you had the Access Hollywood
tape and all that kind of stuff
well the emails gave conservatives and
conservative media something else to
focus on to try to change the subject so
it did help him in that way there's no
denying it but is it the reason he got
elected you know is that why voters in
the Rust Belt came out for Trump is
because of because of that I tend to
think not all right so that's really
briefly that's the the collusion element
of it and the big takeaway is again
Russia did interfere in the election and
but there's no evidence or no reason to
believe that Trump was involved in
including at all the second section is
more interesting let me read the
of that section it says because we
determined not to make a traditional
prosecutorial judgment we did not draw
ultimate conclusions about the
president's conduct the this is in
reference to obstruction the evidence we
obtained about the president's actions
and intent presents difficult issues
that we would need to be resent what
that would need to be resolved if we
were to make a traditional prosecutorial
judgment at the same time if we had
confidence after a thorough
investigation of the facts that the
president clearly did not commit
obstruction of justice we would so state
based on the facts and the applicable
legal standards we are unable to reach
that judgment accordingly while this
report does not conclude that the
president committed a crime it also does
not exonerate him so Muller leaves the
possibility open that Trump tried to
obstruct but says that he can't arrive
at that conclusion he's not arriving at
that conclusion he does not conclude
that Trump committed a crime he also
doesn't conclude the Trump didn't commit
a crime okay which is now which is what
we expected right that actually is what
if you if you were paying attention what
Barr was saying that's kind of what we
expected and even before Barr said
anything or summarized the report that's
kind of what I expected anyway it seemed
clear to me after two years and all the
various leaks that were coming out that
this was this was not going to be a
report saying here's evidence that Trump
committed a crime and indeed that is not
what's in the report but I also never
expected that we were actually going to
get a report at the end of this that has
conclusive statements of the president's
innocence whether or not he's actually
innocent right it's significant though
that the crime or potential crime being
referred to in that section is not
collusion but obstruction so the
conclusion thing is out the window there
was no conclusion collusion which means
that there's there's no underlying crime
in other words Trump could not have been
trying to obstruct justice in order to
stop people from finding out about
collusion
because there was no collusion and that
point really matters I think because it
goes to intent and this is what Barr
said at his press conference and it's
what molar mentions as well in the
report that Trump may have been acting
in ways that arguably appear adjacent to
obstruction but not out of criminal
intent but out of anger and his sincere
belief that this was a partisan witch
hunt
now the left is when when Barr said that
in the press conference the left course
had a temper tantrum like they're in a
constant state of having temper tantrums
as I was what does that matter what is
it is intent if he was angry and he was
frustrated
it does matter of course your intent
matters when you're when when we are
looking at the possibility of a crime
being committed so and again that is
basically what I always kind of assumed
and I think it's what probably a lot of
us assume that that Trump is not a
secret Russian agent now I'm glad that
we have this we have that kind of
spelled out in the report now but I
never really took that seriously it just
didn't that just didn't didn't pass the
smell test for me the idea that Trump
was you know secretly devising this plan
with the Russian government so he's not
that but he is reckless and angry all
the time and he's a loudmouth and he has
just no prudence or discernment at all
so and that gets him into trouble and I
already knew that also I think we all
already knew that he's not he's not a
criminal mastermind he's just a reckless
loudmouth which isn't good now I'm not
one of these people says I was great you
know I haven't a president out there
that's acting just like us well you know
I don't actually don't think he is
acting just like normal people and most
normal people I know don't act like that
and I don't think it's good for a
president to carry on that way but it's
not criminal you know these are that's
something that voters can take in in
consideration when it comes time to vote
and if they don't want a president that
acts that way they don't have to vote
for him but this is not a criminal thing
let's look at one example from the
report this just I think kind of
encapsulate sir this is one example for
this is this is something that the left
right now is taking as proof of Trump's
guilt or as indication of his guilt but
then when you look in full context you
see what Trump was actually getting at
and what the point really is so let me
pull this up it's just one little
portion but I think it's pretty
revealing so in the obstruction section
we have this under the heading of
evidence we have we have this it says on
May 17 2017 acting Attorney General
Rosenstein appointed Robert S Mulliken
cyl and authorized him to conduct the
Russia investigation and matters that
arose from the investigation the
president learned of the special
counsels appointments from sessions who
was with the president hunt and began
conducting interviews for a new FBI
director sessions stepped out of the
Oval Office to take a call from
Rosenstein who told him about the
Special Counsel appointment and sessions
then returned to inform the president of
the news according to the notes written
by hunt when sessions I've got a cat
walking around the background as you can
see this is a very serious man is a
professional opera I mean I'm talking
about something serious here and this is
this is we're talking about Russian
collusion and I've got a cat walking
around um all right where was I so
according to notes written by hunt when
when sessions told the president that a
special counsel had been appointed the
president's temp slumped back in his
chair and said oh my god this is
terrible this is the end of my
presidency
I'm effed okay that's well that's what
the president said the president became
angry and lambasted the Attorney General
for his decision to recuse from the
investigation stating how could you let
this happen Jeff the president said the
position of attorney general was his
most important appointment and that's
Head quote let him down contrasting him
to Eric Holder and Robert Kennedy okay
and then sessions were called the
president said to him you were supposed
to protect me or words that effect okay
so you've got that part right there and
that's the part that just just one
little part of the report that you're
gonna see if you go on Twitter or
Facebook you're gonna see it all over
the place and the left is making a lot
of hay out of this saying well hey he
found out about the special counsel
being being being appointed and any and
he said he was he said he was effed
right he said he was he said his
presidency was over obviously he said
said a mission of guilt well hold on a
second and by the way even even if that
is what's going on in this little
anecdote nothing that I've just read to
you is obstruction of justice now this
is under the header of evidence of
potential evidence I suppose of
obstruction not nothing that he said
here is obstruction even if he is
worried that he oh he is a secret
Russian agent now they're gonna find out
and he says oh oh my god this is
terrible how could you do this to me how
that's not obstruction and what in what
sense would that be obstruction but they
leave out the next part and it's just
the very next sentence they cut this
part out it says the president returned
to the consequences of the appointment
and said everyone tells me if you get
one of these in independent counsels it
ruins your presidency it takes years and
years and I won't be able to do anything
this is the worst thing that ever
happened to me okay so that's some
necessary context and there's a reason
why you're gonna you're gonna say that
line about I'm f that's gonna be all
over the place that probably already is
but they're gonna leave out the next
part so why did he think he was effed
well he explains it it's not because oh
I they're gonna find out you know the
the the jig is up they're gonna they're
gonna discover no it's he's worried
about the political implications of
having an independent counsel
investigating you that's what he's
concerned about
it's the political implications and how
this is going to harm his presidency and
he was right to be concerned about those
things so not only is this not
obstruction but it only I think
reinforces his case that the thing he
was worried about was just the whole
spectacle of it and how this was going
to hurt his ability to get things done
so that's the kind of thing we're
talking about Trump was worried about
the about political implications and so
whatever actions he considered taking or
did take or things that he said it was
all on his part it would seem with the
knowledge that he didn't do what they're
accusing him of doing and he treated
this thing like a ridiculous fishing
expedition which it turns out it was and
that is the headline now I'm not look
I'm not a trump apologist I think I can
claim that and I have credibility as
someone who's not a trouble apologist I
have no problem criticizing Trump I do
it all the time and there's plenty of
stuff in this report from what just from
what I've read like I said I've only
read small part of it but there's plenty
of stuff in this report that yeah I wish
the president hadn't said that I wish he
was you know could control himself more
even that reaction there yeah he was
around people that he trusted but still
I mean the fact that we have a president
just can't control his mouth is it's
it's I don't like it I wish that he
could I wasn't one of those people that
during the campaign I there's like
that's the thing they like most about
them well it's it's it is not that is
not an advantage for a president that is
not a thing that helps right it gets in
the way as we're seeing so yeah there's
it's it's it's not like every little
thing in this report is wonderful for
Trump politically speaking but there is
no evidence of a crime he's not he's not
being charged with a crime there is no
conclusion that a crime was committed
there's no evidence of a crime and
that's it that's the headline
and all the rest of it even the even the
potentially politically damaging aspects
of it really won't affect him because
everything's baked into the cake at this
point if you already at this point we're
now
you know three years in you feel however
you feel about Trump if you hate him
then you you're gonna hate them you
hated him before this report you're
gonna hate him afterwards whatever is in
the report you're going to see in the
most negative possible light and that's
just the way it is so it doesn't even
matter what the report says if you love
him if you're if you're a huge Trump fan
to Trump groupie then you loved him
before the report you gonna love him
after everything in the report you're
going to see the most positive light
possible so it doesn't even really
matter what the report says and if
you're like me and you're you know you
try to take a less simplistic approach
to Trump where you you know you don't
see him as simplistically villainous nor
as a simplistically heroic but you're
somewhere in between then you know again
this report seems to kind of fit into
that paradigm so even politically I
don't think that this is going to have
any effect whatsoever if it does have
some effect I think it will probably be
more on the positive end because
although the left may want us to forget
they may want to change the subject we
are not going to be able to forget that
the thing that they spent the last two
years talking about was collusion
collusion collusion collusion that's
what they were talking about and the
fact of the matter is if you look at the
report he's he is essentially vindicated
of that charge even if that word isn't
used even if a word like exonerated is
not used essentially for all intents and
purposes he is he didn't do it there is
no reason to think that he colluded with
Russia and so if anything I think this
probably is gonna help because because
of that because that was their focus now
they're gonna try to shift you can hear
and see the goalposts being uprooted and
dragged across the field they're
shifting the goalposts now and now
you're not going to hear anything more
about collusion collusions out the
window
now you're gonna hear about obstruction
they want this to be a story about
obstruction but that's not what this
ever was about for them it was about
collusion and so that's got to be the
headline that there is no collusion and
the case for obstruction is obviously
even before you read that part of the
report the case for obstruction is going
to be severely undermined by the fact
that there is no underlying crime that a
person would be obstructing to try to
hide alright um I did have a couple
other things I wanted to mention today
here's an interesting tidbit the
charitable giving of both Bernie Sanders
and Beto O'Rourke have recently come
under scrutiny
Bernie's tax returns reveal that he is
now a millionaire but he gives a very
small percentage of his income to
charity
Beto also gives a small percentage and
he was asked about it recently at a I
don't have the clip but he was asked
about a campaign stop about the fact
that he only gave like I think was like
a thousand bucks or something I'm in two
thousand bucks the charity in 2017 and
his answer was that yeah he he doesn't
give money to charity but he has given
the gift of himself to society and so
that's that's as good as check it's even
better than charity now I don't know
what that really achieves practically
speaking for the homeless and the
destitute who need the chair and the
charitable giving but that's the answer
that he went with now usually I would
say that the charitable giving of a
politician is really not a relevant
issue for us to consider that's between
them and their conscience and God but
when the politician is someone who
frequently rails against greed and
demands that our entire economic system
be transformed so as to he claims take
better care of the less fortunate and
that liberty and economic freedom have
to be curtailed in that quest then all
of a sudden this person's own charitable
giving or lack thereof I think does
become relevant and it is certainly
relevant in Sanders case it's also
relevant you know
lesser extent but still relevant with
O'Rourke as well because this is a very
significant flaw in the Socialists
mentality this is where they lose the
game because if you've got a bunch of
would-be socialists in a country if
you've got a bunch of wannabe socialist
people who who would favor socialism as
we do in this country according to the
polls we have a sizable portion of
especially Millennials who claim that
socialism is the way to go
well then if all of these people could
negate the need for socialism by
instituting a voluntary form of it among
themselves they could give massive
chunks of their own wealth to the poor
and the less fortunate they could give
as much in taxes to the IRS as they want
they could have their socialist utopia
right now but they don't and why is that
because for politicians like Sanders
this is what's revealed it's socialism
is about power if Sanders really cared
about the principles of we can even call
them principles of socialism then he
would at a minimum be doing whatever he
could in his own personal life to live
according to those principles and to
enact them in whatever small way he can
the fact that he's not shows you that
for him socialism is about power because
a socialist government is a powerful
government and so therefore socialists
you know the the the politicians of the
socialist government are very powerful
politicians and for socialist citizens
who who do not who choose not to give
much of their money away to the poor or
pay more in taxes than they have to
which again they could do but you see
that socialism for them is about helping
themselves not others okay so the whole
thing is inherently self-interested and
self-centered and that's just what it is
all of the moral the moral language that
they cloak their socialist advocacy in
that all of that is bogus
because whatever they're claiming
socialism would do for this country they
could start doing that now but they
choose not to all right one other thing
there was a video going viral yesterday
which I won't play for you because I
don't think it's really necessary but
the video is it's pretty familiar
unfortunately it shows a fight between
two female students it looks like looks
like high school students at some school
I don't know the details doesn't really
matter I call it a fight but what you
see in the video is one girl smack
another girl in the face with a textbook
and then start pummeling her while the
while the girls sitting down and the
victim does not seem like she's able or
willing or interested in defending
herself so it's more of a beating than a
fight the point though is that the
students are all sitting and watching of
course as they always do some of it or
some of them are recording it on their
phone while the teacher is yelling for
people to put their phones away and he's
telling someone else to run and go get
the principal but he's being widely
criticized now it's a male teacher by
the way the guy he's being widely
criticized for not physically
intervening which in the video he
doesn't he's being called a coward and
so on for sending for help but not for
physically trying to stop it and you see
the teachers get criticized on the on
this ground pretty often when you see
these videos of fights in school and
everyone says well why aren't the
teacher stepping in now I'm not shy
about criticizing teachers as you know
but I'm gonna defend them here because I
think a lot of people just don't
appreciate what these teachers are up
against and the situation they're in
because here is that situation at many
of these schools fights like that happen
every single day constantly and they
happen every day because awful parents
send their awful kids to school hoping
that the schools will do the raising for
them but schools aren't equipped for
that schools cannot be foster parents
for your kids
all the schools can do is just damage
control they all they can do is just try
to
try to control things in the moment as
much as possible but we also live in a
very litigious society and a society
where blame is often cast on the wrong
people and part of the reason for that
is that those awful parents are also
awful people in general and they will
not hesitate therefore to try and ruin a
teacher's life and career or worse if he
in the mind of the awful parent goes too
far in disciplining their precious awful
little child so what that means is that
a teacher who makes physical contact
with a student of any kind especially a
male teacher with a female student if
he's trying to break even if he's trying
to break up a fight he could easily end
up fired sued in jail maybe all three
and remember this crap happens every day
so if every teacher just decided to
throw caution to the wind and open
themselves up to litigation or legal
penalty every time there's a fight and
you know rush in there physically and
try to break it up then after a week
there'd be no teachers left I do think
there are situations where a teacher is
morally obliged to get involved even at
the risk of severe penalty if for
instance a you know a mentally or
physically disabled student is being
physically assaulted which which does
happen and in that case I think it's you
know whatever the consequences are you
got to step in and in this situation I
have no idea what the story is between
the two girls so I can't speak
specifically to it but I'm more
interested in just making a general
point here most of the time fights
between students are not cases of good
guy versus bad guy most of the time it's
not a case of bully verse victim that's
usually not how it works
sometimes it is but but usually not
usually you've got too bad loud mouthed
brats who are going after each other
that's most how most fights work even if
one is pummeling the other you know most
of the time the one getting pummeled is
also a bully and a brat who just in this
case is getting the the
and of the deal so my point is do we
expect a teacher to sacrifice
potentially his whole career and his
financial security and his freedom in
order to get in between two
out-of-control brats no I don't and I
wouldn't if I was in that position I
don't know I'm not gonna think I'm gonna
give up it yeah I'm gonna put myself in
that position for these two kids no as
long as nobody's getting killed or
something
I wouldn't expect teachers to make that
kind of sacrifice why should they again
I don't know if that was the case in
this particular instance but but
generally speaking we have to understand
what teachers are up against they've got
bad kids bad parents a bad system and
their hands are tied behind their backs
there's nothing they can do or are
allowed to do so what do we expect them
to do they are it in in many of these
schools especially in the worst you know
the the worst sorts of these kinds of
schools public schools
there's just they are putting in a
really impossible situation where they
are constantly facing scenarios where
there's no good option for them and so
what do we expect in this look this is
the inevitable result when you live in a
litigious society and you know everyone
no one takes personal responsibility
everything's being recorded all the time
and you know that that parents will will
usually take the side of their own child
even if their child is clearly in the
wrong when you're in that position it's
just Minaya you're gonna start
protecting yourself a little bit and you
should and believe me I mean there are
you know any any teacher could tell
horror stories but don't think for a
minute I mean if you
but a teacher gets involved in a fight
and then himself gets assaulted in the
process and this happens all the time
and then tries to physically restrain
that the student who was assaulting him
the parents of that student in many
cases will claim that no their child is
the victim and now they're gonna sue I
mean that's that's what happens all
right let's go to emails Matt Walsh show
at gmail.com Matt Walsh show at
gmail.com we'll do a couple of emails
here it says this is from Michael so
it's good sir I listen to your show
every day most the time I agree with you
however your statement about McDonald's
being the best fast-food is just wrong
chick-fil-a is superior chicken so tasty
will always be better than McDonald's
keep up the good work Michael it goes
without saying that chick-fil-a has the
best fast-food chicken but they're
they're one-dimensional because all they
do is chicken and and honestly the only
really excellent item on the chick-fil-a
menu is the chicken sandwich they're you
know their fries are overrated I'm
afraid to say their salads are mediocre
their raps are actually bad
so they earn an a-plus on chicken
sandwiches but then they get like c's
and d's for everything else
whereas McDonald's is just a McDonald's
doesn't get an a-plus on anything right
but but they get a solid b-plus
you know maybe B b-minus on everything
everything they do is a BB - you know
bye-bye fast-food standards they don't
have the best chicken that's that's
chick-fil-a they don't have the best
hamburgers that's Hardee's they don't
have the best fries that's Arby's but
they just they're just solid in every
area and they know how they know what
they're doing and they get you and they
get you out and so that's why when it
all what it all comes down to it the
McDonald's is McDonald's is the king of
fast food for a reason I think they
actually are they actually are number
one let's see here this is from
Nathaniel says Matt I loved your
argument for beautiful churches I have
been saying that this is one of my
biggest problems with the Protestant
tradition I myself in a
non-denominational Protestant how
I think you probably mischaracterized
the point about idols I agree that
nobody's worshipping the Notre Dame as a
God but it is possible to elevate beauty
to highly and worship beauty itself as
an idol rather than God
we need food in our lives just like
beauty but Millennials in almost every
major city have turned food into an idol
and worship at the Church of the next
hippest restaurant and join in the
Liturgy of brunch the Liturgy of brunch
actually sounds kind of appealing I just
think you probably missed the point of
their argument or at least a better
point they should have made I love your
show and thank you for the work you put
into sharing good philosophy in theology
he's responding to a point I was making
but you know we need beautiful churches
and there are some Christians who argue
that well if you got a bunch of statues
and art and everything then it becomes
idol worship of the of the statues which
i think is honestly kind of an absurd
criticism because nobody in a Christian
Church is worshipping a statue like
we're not that's just not an inclination
anyone has we know that the statue
itself is not God we know that it's just
a statue but it's beautiful you know and
it symbolizes something and it makes us
think of that which it symbolizes so I
understand your point Nathanael and it's
not a stupid point by any means what
when you when you broaden it to talk
about the kind of other forms of idol
worship in our society I agree with that
but I do think that the whole people
turning things into idols criticism is
sometimes overstated what I mean is how
can you tell the difference between
someone just really liking something
really appreciating it and turning it
into an idol I think often from the
outside you can't really tell the
difference because you can't know their
heart and we can sometimes confuse the
former with the latter or the latter
with the former so that's the problem
you mentioned that you mentioned the
hipster foodies right well yeah some of
them may make it an idol of it I suppose
but I think some people just really like
food and they're interested in it and
they like to learn about it they like to
try it it's an interest they have they
like to cook it and that's fine it's
fine to have that passion it's not idol
worship that's good I would say that
something becomes an idol when it takes
an undue priority over other
in your life that should be more
important so a guy who would rather play
video games than be with his family is
is has turned video games into an idol
not because he thinks that the video
game is God literally but just because
he has put it above he has put it in a
place where it doesn't belong he's put
it above other things that are more
objectively important so does anyone
really sort of downgrade more important
things so that they can focus on
beautiful artwork and icons and statues
and so on at church is anyone in church
going well I can't think about God right
now because I'm just blown away by this
statue I mean maybe it's possible but I
think the whole point of religious art
and icons and statues and stained glass
along along with the music by the way is
to elevate our spirits our minds and
bring us closer into communion with the
divine that's that's what it does it's
so when you see a beautiful so that the
you know the Pieta I think the most
beautiful sculpture ever ever sculpted
but when I look at that yeah there is a
moment of just marveling at the skill
and the beauty of it and what must have
gone into carving this thing out of a
block of stone so there's that but then
very quickly your mind goes to thinking
about what this statue represents and
what it depicts which is the mother of
Jesus holding him in her arms after he's
taken out from the cross and so you
start thinking about that you think
about the cross you think about this and
that so I think that's what art does and
that's why it's good to have it in a
church because it makes you think for a
moment about the thing itself if it's
beautiful but then it quickly brings
your mind to the greater thing as I
mentioned I really think that if we're
worried about art distracting from God
at church or becoming an idol as it were
the real worry is not with paintings or
sculptures which people look at and
appreciate and then
most inadvertently from their minds they
you know from there they begin thinking
about other things I think the real
worry is is not with that but with music
which is also art in a church right now
music can really become an idol I think
it can really become essentially the
point of the whole experience and the
church band becomes like a mini rock
band and they're all little mini rock
musicians who are glorifying themselves
rather than God that can happen it does
happen and it is in my mind a much
greater concern than some inanimate
sculpture becoming anyone's idol I think
it's much more likely that the band
leader or even the pastor will become an
idol all right this is from Taylor says
hi Matt I agree with most of what you
say but I think you are hypocritical in
one area you say you want to reduce
abortions which will probably mean more
children up for adoption but you would
rather leave children in orphanages than
allow loving gay couples to adopt them
do you really think it's better for a
child to be in a foster home than
adopted by a gay couple and how does
this work with you're pro-life beliefs
Taylor sorry I think there are a few
things here we have to work through
first of all the hypothetical abolition
of abortion would not result in a whole
bunch of babies stuck in purgatory in
the system for years on end there is no
problem in this country with babies not
finding families to adopt them that's a
myth and that's something you hear from
pro-abortion people all the times well
hey look you know if you if we don't
kill the babies and they're gonna all be
in the system forever even if that was
true it's a really bad reason to kill a
child not that there could ever be a
good reason but it's not true it's now
there are children who sadly tragically
end up in the system sometimes until
they're 18 and are never adopted but
those are children who end up in the
system when they're older like when
they're 6 or 7 it is hard to get a 6 or
7 year old kid adopted unfortunately but
the the
rush of new children into the system
that would happen from abolishing
abortion these would not be six year old
kids these would be infants and there is
no problem with getting infants adopted
there are there so there's a waiting
list fifty miles long of people who are
just waiting to adopt an infant so
there's absolutely no problem with that
so if we ended up with a hundred
thousand new infant infants up for
adoption who would have otherwise been
aborted all of those infants will get
adopted in pretty short order so so
there's there's that so this idea that
we would need to expand adoption to gay
couples in order to get all the kids
adopted just not true the second point
is that you know in my mind every child
needs and deserves a mother and father
and that's a biological need there's a
reason why every child in history every
person in history has been created by a
mother and father so even you know even
if you don't want to use the word god
let's say nature clearly intends for
every child to have a mother and father
which is why every child does have a
mother and father even if their mother
and father are unable or unwilling to
care for them so what I would ask you is
if we're talking about gay adoption
which of the two is expendable in your
mind mother or father I mean you clearly
think that one of them is expendable so
if we're talking about two gay men
adopting a child so you think the mother
is we just you know we are doesn't need
a mother hey what did I can do that well
here's the thing a guy can't do that
actually a man cannot function as a
mother and so a man can be a very loving
father but he cannot be a mother that is
just not a role that he can but
biologically fulfill and there is a
certain there are certain emotional
psychological needs that a child has
that if he doesn't have a mother at home
will not be met now that
mean that he's doomed doesn't mean the
child's doom doesn't mean the child is
gonna you know it can't end up being
happy and fulfilled in life but he will
be happy and fulfilled in spite of that
disadvantage because it is a
disadvantage so that's the point you
know you there there are plenty of
people that live in plenty of kids that
are in single-parent homes and now many
of those kids will end up with very
difficult lives but some of them will
well in the end end up being perfectly
well rounded well-adjusted people but it
will be B it will be in spite of that
disadvantage it is definitely a
disadvantage to be deprived of a mother
or father and what I'm saying is if
you've got a kid in the system rather
than sort of like settling and saying
well you know we'll probably never find
a mother for this kid so we'll just you
know well yeah what we'll settle for
that instead - dad's good enough it's
really not though there's that you could
have ten dads it's there there's there
are no number of dads that are going to
amount to one mom just like there are no
amount of women that are going to amount
to one dad because the dad also fulfills
certain emotional psychological needs of
the child and child needs and deserves
both and so that's my point it doesn't
really matter how you you know whatever
you feel about homosexuality or you know
gay marriage or whatever it's almost
like you could put that issue to the
side because this is about the needs of
the child
nothing really political about it
alright we'll leave it there thanks for
watching everybody thanks for listening
enjoy your night spent reading the
Moller report although honestly I think
there are better ways to spend your
night but Godspeed I'm Michael Knowles
host of the Michael Knowles show
Attorney General William Bar has
released the Mulla report with
relatively few redactions he gives a
highly entertaining press conference on
the details of its release we
we'll analyze all the relevant sections
the good the bad and the ugly check it
out of daily wire calm